bonjour à vous et merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur air france est ce qu'il ya
des discussions entamées avec la
direction de sanofi alors écoutez
discussions en termes de si vous parlez
des suppressions de postes d'écouté non
il n'y a pas de discussion
la direction va lancer son plan de
réduction d'effectifs et notamment la
fermeture du site de sera jours et pour
l'estac pour la direction où il est hors
de question de faire marche arrière sur
sur les suppressions de postes alors
pourquoi ces suppressions de postes ne
sont pas justifiées ce mouvement
bah écoute et une pour nous c'est qu'à
romagne seulement des suppressions de
postes pour favoriser les profits du
groupe
d'autant plus que c'est d'autant plus
grave aujourd'hui que ces suppressions
de postes touchent la partie recherche
en chimie et il faut savoir aujourd'hui
que nos usines de production
fonctionnent à 90% sur sur des principes
actifs pour la fabrication de principes
actifs d'origine de synthèse donc donc
de chimie cela veut dire que si
aujourd'hui la recherche dans la chimie
s'arrête ça veut dire que dans les
années à venir il y aura plus
d'activités sur sur nos sites de
production en france
alors lors du premier confinement on va
rappeler ces chiffres sanofi a cumulé
près de 11 milliards de dollars de
chiffre d'affaires et enregistré 4
milliards de dividendes à ses
actionnaires
lorsque vous avancez ces chiffres à la
direction que vous répondons
ah bah écoutez la direction nous renvoie
à feu à ce que parce que les la
concurrence peut faire les freezers et
compagnie et chaque fois on nous
explique que si on verse pas de
dividende le groupe se met ce mais ce
peut se mettre en difficulté et pour
être racheté par par une voix de notre
groupe pharmaceutique
donc en gros nous nous dirigeons gains
distribués à tout va des dividendes
protège protège avant tout avant tout
leur poste il ya des est vu comme une
idée élus de la france soumise qui
soutiennent votre mobilisation c'est la
deuxième fois que
vous vous mobilisez devant le siège de
sanofi
comment est-ce que vous jugez la posture
des autorités dans ce dossier vis-à-vis
de sanofi
écoutez on a on est rentré en contact
plusieurs reprises avec avec le cabinet
de bruno launay le maire
écoutez pour eux il n'y a rien de
nouveau
les annonces de suppressions de postes
avait été déjà fait pour moi de au mois
de juin 2020 et pour pour les autorités
à il n'y a pas péril en la demeure
sanofi le groupe privé et pour pour nos
autorités a pas pas de moyens d'action
pour eux ils vont juste rester vigilant
à ce que sanofi respecte les engagements
en termes d'emplois que que sanofi a vu
qu prendre autant dire que pour nos
gouvernants le sanofi la problématique
de l'emploi et de la recherche de sanofi
c'est pas pour eux c'est pas un problème
disait il ya des élus qui vous soutient
les élus communistes de la france a
soumis de ce que vous souhaiteriez une
large mobilisation de la classe
politique
écoutez je pense qu'aujourd'hui notre
notre recherche en général est malade
effectivement il faut qu' il faut que la
classe politique s'empare aussi de de ce
sujet parce qu'au final c'est quand même
eux qui font nos lois et secteurs qui
vont au budget alors parfois il faut
sous sous la pression de l'opinion
publique et de la population
mais aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya même
plus besoin d'y avoir de pression on
voit bien que notre recherche qu'elles
soient publiques ou privées est malade
et il faut absolument qu'ils ont une
réaction est effectivement aujourd'hui
se mobilisent et que le politique se
mobilise contre les suppressions de
postes supérieures qui peut y avoir deux
dans sanofi c'est une c'est une façon de
démontrer que voilà il faut que les
choses évoluent et que les choses
évoluent dans le bon sens et il faut que
ben que la france retrouve retrouve
toute sa souveraineté interne en termes
de recherche et pour nous de la
souveraineté est le passe d'abord par
papa parle par le service public et pas
forcément parler d'entreprises privées
même si on peut imaginer qu'ils aient du
travail qui soit fait entre le privé et
le public
alors vous savez que sanofi va aider à
la production la fabrication du fac du
vaccin father biotech
vous pensez que face aux enjeux autour
justement des vaccins sanofi garde la
main malgré tout et c'est difficile
aujourd'hui de de s'en prendre aux
groupes pharmaceutiques
alors écoutez déjà sanofi va pas
participer à la fabrication du vaccin
sanofi va faire du flaconnage c'est à
dire que le va mettre la solution d un
flacco et elle va faire ça sur sur le
site de francfort à l'allemagne donc de
là à dire que sanofi participent à la
fabrication du vaccin
c'est quand même c'est quand même un peu
fort et c'est allé vite en besogne nous
par contre ce que l'on donne
effectivement c'est que peut-être pas
pour les pour les vaccins arn messagers
heures parce que c'est peut-être la
technologie peut être un peu plus
compliqué et on ne peut pas toujours
forcément la mettre en place comme ça en
claquant des doigts
mais par contre s'il ya d'autres vaccins
qui vont arriver sur le marché et qui
pot pour lesquelles sanofi maîtrise à
100 % que le procédé de fabrication et
nous ce que l'on demande c'est que pour
ces vaccins là les chaînes de production
disponibles de chez sanofi soit
réquisitionné si sanofi veut pas ne pas
les mettre à disposition des populations
nous vous rappelle quand même comme un
président qui nous a expliqué que le
vaccin serait un bien commun pour
l'humanité aujourd'hui elle s'aperçoit
que le bien commun si on regarde pfizer
et ces annonces ce bien commun
représente quand même 15 milliard
d'euros pour 15 milliard d'euros 2,2
de chiffre d'affaires pour pfizer donc
un bien commun 15/1 milliard d'euros
vous m'excuserez mais des fois il ya des
mots ce sont peut-être pas forcément
adapté à une réalité
donc nous que ce soit réellement un bien
commun et ce que l'on demande c'est que
les licences de ses vaccins soient soin
de ton dans le domaine public et que
n'importe quel état puisque les utiliser
notamment la france et idem pour pour
pour les biens de production
il faut absolument réquisitionner des
biens de production et la mobilisation
aujourd'hui pour conclure comment
s'annonce-t-elle l'a écoutée sur sur le
site de vitry apparemment les nouvelles
que j'ai eues il ya sur le sol plutôt
sont plutôt bonnes
il ya une centaine de salariés se sont
réunis ce site de vitry après une phrase
on a douze sites sur les 24 où il ya des
appels à la mobilisation ou des appels à
la grève débutée voilà on essaie de
faire le maximum pour se faire entendre
et pourrait pour dénoncer cette
situation de suppressions de postes et
puis il faut bien savoir ça va au delà
des suppressions de postes dans ce
groupe un réel mal être
quand toute la journée dans nos usines
dans nos bureaux ont croisé salariés qui
nous disent mais quand à quand le
prochain plan social pour que je suis
tous puissent partir ça veut dire qu'il
ya un problème quand des salariés sont
prêts à cuire qui a quitté du sinn et
les bureaux séquelles il ya quelque
chose qui ne va pas je vous rappelle que
le
la société sanofi aventis groupe a été
mise mise en demeure par par la direccte
d'ile-de-france pour pour mise en
demeure pour non respect sur des risques
psychosociaux c'est à dire que là
aujourd'hui la direccte domaine de des
comptes à sanofi sur les risques
psychosociaux parce qu'on est sûr sur
des dents sur des dans une société où
ben vous avez des suicides et tentatives
de suicides des 5 des gens qui cette
vraie malle et voilà donc il faut bien
comprendre que ça fait 13 ans qu'on
subit des plans d'économies sur plan
d'économies en domaine de faire beaucoup
d'efforts aux salariés et en retour il
n'y a pas grand chose voire rien du tout
donc et chaque fois qui a en retour
c'est un retour de c1 retour de bateaux
il ya nous parle de suppressions de
postes donc là stop ça suffit
et voilà les salariés de sanofi mérite
mérite autre chose et le groupe mérite
certainement d'autres dirigeants que ce
qu'elle a à l'heure actuelle
merci beaucoup à vous jean louis perrin
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions rappelle que vous êtes
coordinateur cgt
sanofi vous